rendez vous donc demain soir à rades la
butte montmartre est en effervescence en
effet un projet est à l'étude pour mme
interdire l'accès au car de touristes
d'un côté les commerçants et les
voyagistes qui ont besoin des touristes
et qui sont favorables aux autobus dans
les rues de la butte de l'autre les
riverains qui ne peuvent plus circuler
dans les rues de leur quartier et dont
les maisons s'affaisse dangereusement et
pour être tout à fait complet n'oublions
pas la position des prêtres du sacré
coeur qui eux sont favorables au
tourisme et qu'un message ray selon
certaines rumeurs de céder quelques
terrains pour les transformer en parking
sur la complète la complainte pardon de
la butte nouvelle version le reportage
de clément weill raynal
à la butte mon arc paradis des touristes
et des pigeons un paradis du qu'elle
risque de se voir chassés les autocars
ces poids lourds tourisme sont menacés
de rester d'amener à tout jamais
boulevard de rochechouart en effet la
mairie de paris envisage sous la
pression des riverains de leur interdire
la montée vers le sacré coeur outre les
et les encombrements les riverains
soutiennent que le passage de ces
mastodontes provoque ébranlement et
fissures dans leurs habitations en
raison également des anciennes carrières
de la butte montmartre qui ont rendu le
terrain instable
les voyagistes conscient du problème
mais ne vois pas vraiment de solution
s'il y avait des parkings au pied de la
butte montmartre
le problème serait simplement déplacé
car comment ces touristes étrangers
viendrait-il sur la butte quand on sait
qu'ils sont en moyenne deux à trois
jours de séjour à paris comment peut-on
supposer qu'il monterait à pied en haut
de la butte montmartre qu'il prendrait
du temps pour cela alors qu'ils veulent
visiter la butte montmartre dans des
conditions de confort et de rapidité
compatible avec la durée de leur séjour
pour les voyagistes plus d'autocars plus
de touristes les autocars ne doivent pas
devenir les boucs émissaires clament les
professionnels comptent une petite
voiture bloc 1 k c'est toujours le plus
gros qui est montré du doigt d'accord
pour réglementer le stationnement sur la
butte montmartre disent les voyagistes
mais pour les voitures comme pour les
autres un allié est de taille pour les
tours opérators les autorités
ecclésiastiques qui préfèrent la foi
inébranlable des pèlerins aux
ébranlement des édifices
nous pensons qu'il faut essayer de tenir
compte de ce désir de millions de
personnes même qui désirent venir à nos
marques et ne pas trouver trop vite des
palliatifs qui dans son passé
intérêts à défendre l'intérêt
militairement cibler avons nous intérêt
personnel est propre même je dois
prendre quelques fois un petit
dérangement dans le fait que évidemment
c'est plus à la campagne s'était fait
que dernier ici donc ça je pense que la
belgique est pas menacée effectivement
puisque droite je vais savoir que les
bâtis sur 30 86 pilier 30 mètres de
profondeur évidemment c'est une solide
en matinée et ça permet évidemment
d'envisager pas mal de choix une réunion
de conciliation est prévue le 23 juillet
à la mairie une solution pourrait en
sortir si les voies du seigneur sont
impénétrables celle qui mène au
sacré-coeur ne devrait pas être
totalement bloqué